mike catherwood was saying uh how it's
such a bummer that there's no
you know kevin being all that skin
cancel and he's talking about how you
got your start with
jimmy kimmel was on there and you were
helping him get ready for some like
boxing competition is that right
yeah it's a and then they would bring
you in they're like dude this guy's
hilarious and smart as [ __ ] why isn't he
doing this why are we doing this
it should be i don't know something for
the kids listening um i was like
i i i i wasn't a highly motivated guy i
was kind of a [ __ ] up
i was a bad student i didn't go to
college i hung around with sort of
fuck-ups from the valley we
clean carpets and work construction and
stuff like that
and i was like the whole story is kind
of kind of interesting
in that i gave myself this timeline i
was like by the time you're 30
you got to be doing something like
something i i wasn't thinking about
famous tv
i was like i was like 21 or 22.
give yourself a lot of time i did i i
did that's for seniority
by the time you're 90 40. that's [ __ ]
patience yeah by the time you get to
clint eastwood's current age
you my friend no i was like what i did
i i did like i was i was totally
realistic about it like i was like
21 living with these you know three
dudes in a one bedroom
in north hollywood you know no air
crappy apartment
everyone just worked construction drove
a pickup truck you know
nothing like you know drinking shaffer
beer on the weekends and
ripping bong loads and trying to get
lane everything no insurance
no parents had no money no no nothing i
didn't have car insurance i didn't have
anything
and i was like i was like sitting around
like watching all these idiots
get high all day and sort of just
working for the weekend you know get
your paycheck
nine bucks an hour you know go out to
the lake or whatever
and and i was like 21 or 22 and i was
like how's this going to end like
how are you ever going to get a house i
love cars
i drive a pickup truck i have to drive a
pickup truck for my job
i can't afford a second car i don't have
insurance on my pickup truck
how could i drive a cool car and
with this lifestyle so i was just like
sitting in my apartment in north
hollywood and i was like well what else
could you do
what's a way you could make money and i
thought
you know one way would be more of what
i'm doing like get a contractor's
license
work more hours you know get 15 bucks an
hour you know
and and the other thought was like well
what else are you good at like what
could you do
and i was a [ __ ] student so i knew oh
you're not going to be an attorney or a
doctor
or work in this capacity or that
capacity i really couldn't like fill out
paperwork and work
in a corporate world i was like well
you're funny
you got a sense of humor that's it
that's all all we know about you
is you're good with your hands and and
then you're funny
and i don't know what funny means i
don't know what to do with funny but
at least you have that so i was like all
right
you now have nine years until you're 30.
until you're 30. well i i figured out
like i was like
when you're 20 you can do whatever you
want like you're not a
loser no if you meet a guy and he
doesn't own a home 23
or he doesn't have a second car he's his
career's not taken off and he's like in
his 20s you're like yeah
but when it starts with a three now it's
time and by the way that was the old 30
now
you know guys are 50 and they're [ __ ]
finding themselves on the beach you know
i got a t-shirt company i was thinking
about okay 50 something you have a great
pube dude
maybe you should multi-piercings on the
right here a lot of hoops you driving f1
so whenever anybody who's in their 40s
and 50s gets their first tattoo
hey bro it's over so i'm like
sitting there and going okay by the time
you're 30
something and i i it wasn't such a
general goal
well tony robbins would be like we got
to stop you know let's get more specific
we at that time it's like
the floor collapsed of an outhouse and
i'm up to my neck and [ __ ]
and i'm thinking to myself how do i get
out of this and hose myself
off i'm not thinking about surf and turf
in a martini
and like i'll go i gotta just get to
[ __ ] terra firma and find a garden
hose
so it's like that was the that was my
mindset
like i need a paycheck
i need i want to get paid for christmas
day
you know i mean like in construction
there's no payment whatever christmas
holidays
you roll your ankle playing hoop on a
sunday you don't come in monday you
don't get paid
yeah that that i was like some job maybe
a little security
a business card like maybe i could write
jokes for like a a greeting card company
i could make funny cards or
or i could be part of someone else's
project and write jokes for them or some
you know just or whatever whatever
whatever works but
it wasn't about being in front of the
camera
or on stage or anything but i didn't
rule that out i was just like whatever
so
i didn't know where to go i didn't know
what to do and i found a friend of mine
whose parents who are like kind of in
the industry a little
and i said what should i do where should
i go
and they said there's a place called the
groundlings and it's on like melrose and
you could go sign up for classes
and i was like okay and i just went it
was 350 bucks for
you know 10 classes i didn't have car
insurance but i was like [ __ ] it
i'll go do that and i did that
and and and everyone in the classroom
martin they went to college and they had
this big vocabulary and
and they all kind of like the teacher
would go all right move upstage and i'd
start walking to the left you know no no
not stage left stage right
they're all majors yeah what stage i
like to start following everyone around
and
not turning my back like jim morris into
the audience and stuff
and uh eventually i you know did bunch
of open mics did a ton of
things eventually i was kind of ready
but
i i still had nothing oh we're looking
at
no that's not me and the groundlings
let's see that's
uh that's the there is some old
probably old pictures of me from uh back
back in those days improv troops and
stuff like that i started the acme
theater and
blah blah blah you started the album
acme well it wasn't called the acme
and i ended up building the acme theater
and everything else but anyway
so i i'm a few weeks away from my
30th birthday and i realized
nothing has worked out like i i still
i'm no closer to a job
i got nothing it's it's it's not worked
out like the dream hasn't worked out but
i
do have a job as a boxing coach
at uh it uh god what was it called
uh oh bodies in motion in in pasadena
terrible name i know they had me i built
the gym
i built it out like it was already built
as a structure i just kind of
hung the heavy bags and [ __ ] and then
the guy who worked there said you can
teach
class 20 bucks a class right
so i was working there and i would teach
the morning class
and then i would go work as a carpenter
and i was like i don't know a month away
from turning
30 and i was like i was teaching boxing
i was still working as a carpenter
and the whole comedy thing just
evidently never worked out i had all
this training
yeah but i still wasn't getting paid and
i had nothing
nothing to do and so i was driving my
truck
over uh laurel canyon with my
entertainment unit in the back of it
i've built somebody back when he'd have
the big tv and the pull out drawers or
the vhs rack and everything
and and i hear jimmy kimmel
who's jimmy the sports guy on kevin and
bean
and he's doing the sports and he gets
into an argument like impromptu
with uh michael the maintenance man
who's a you know part of the morning zoo
and they challenge each other to a
boxing match
and and i've listened to k rock my whole
life because i grew up in
los angeles you know in love line and
everything else
and i've never i don't know where the
station is i've never met anybody i
don't know anything like radio is a
weird enigma you know
and they're going all right well we're
going we're having a boxing match and we
need trainers and we need equipment and
we need
gyms if you're listening right now you
know and i'm like drive my truck going
i could train one of those guys to box
and you know you've been boxing at this
point i had been
boxing for
i did the golden gloves when i was 19.
and then i'd stuck with it for
probably 10 years at that point and i
was working
as a trainer at a place that was like
you know executive boxing like fitness
yeah you know but just secretaries and
and you know airline pilots and [ __ ] but
but i was a little more hardcore so like
my class was a little more
like box like we had like mike weaver
work there
and the uh weaver triplets worked there
and mike weaver's like a you want to
talk about a physique
show me mike weaver this guy
you want to talk about a brick [ __ ]
house of a heavyweight
from circa you know 1982
or something holy [ __ ] this guy ain't
juicing i mean i knew mike weaver when
he was
i knew mike weaver when he was 45 he was
up still
good guy jacked wow that's not steroids
ladies and gentlemen
no he's uh you want to talk about just
you want to talk about an incredible
physique
nice guy weaver taught
we were taught that i mean look at that
guy's build from like 1978
you know not so
so he had some credit in boxing so you
just called the station
out of the blue so i get over the hill
it's such a crazy and
uh and the weaver triplets are floyd
lloyd and troy who were the fighting
triplets who were weavers
half kid brothers or whatever you know
heavyweights i got a lot of half can
out there yeah so i went over there i
can't
have can those are the so those guys all
worked at the
the fighting triplets get the [ __ ] out
of here those are the triplets
this is the fighting trip let's say oh
yeah they all worked at bodies in motion
with me it's a little homoerotic
a little bit but
they're good-looking dudes they're
looking dude they've got that
but they're also like they're bodied up
i've seen many pornos like this
have i that looks like you got you you
wouldn't be so much you wandered into
the wrong
definitely click on that keep doing it
hot guys well i mean the owner of the
gym
hated me because mike weaver's like an
ex-heavyweight champ and he's got a
bunch of secretaries so he'd just be
walking by like
punch high punch low punch hot it was
like
everyone's standing squared off you know
just now punch low
and everything and i'm like oh what are
we doing here like we need to teach
people how to box and he's like no one
wants to learn how to box they want to
burn cash
i got the five dudes who wanted to learn
the box not the hot
secretaries of punching the punch low
but anyway
i get over the hill i get to my client's
house
you know pre-cell phone and i like come
in like could i use your phone
and it's like yeah and i i call kevin
and bean
i leave a message i got nothing i keep
calling and leaving messages
there no one calls back i can't get
anything the next day it's like oh we
need trainers we need their call they're
getting them on the air
hey man i'm a trainer oh yeah where you
out of you know
what are qualifications i'm like they're
going to get this dude to train
again jimmy had only been there like
two months and he was doing uh jimmy the
sports guy i didn't know who he was
but michael the maintenance man been
there like four years so i was like i
want to train
the maintenance man but it didn't matter
and eventually
they wouldn't return my call eventually
your goals were so [ __ ] modest i
didn't have anything
i was going to try the maintenance man i
want to see inside the studio that's my
goal i want to see inside the studio
so but it's like a calling to me
so it's interesting yeah eventually i go
[ __ ] it i'm going down there i find out
where the building is it's in burbank's
a commercial building
in burbank and i i go down there and i
have
i'm teaching a 6 30 a.m class
monday wednesday friday whatever it is
so i go down there at like
6 or 5 30 and the whole building's
locked up like you can't get in the
building and then
some guy goes building opens at seven
and i go oh okay i'll come back tomorrow
at seven
and i go back i get a guy to cover my
the second half of my class like i teach
the first half and i run back to burbank
and the building's open and i get into
the buildings like a commercial building
and i go up to the ninth floor where k
rock is but the suite is closed
k rock is like their business hours are
like nine to five like they go when you
pick up your
prize you know you to come after nine
o'clock i know kevin and bean are
in the corner somewhere they're in their
studio but there's no receptionist the
doors are locked
so now i'm like standing out by the
elevators
like going what do i do they don't open
for two hours
i gotta like go back and finish my class
i don't know what to do and like as
i'm pacing around the elevators trying
to figure out like do i go home
a guy comes out of the elevator
he has like a key card and he see him
going around like the back
like to where the service entrance or
the key card you know he's going to
refill the vending machine or drop off
something or whatever
and i'm just like i go with him down the
hall i go are you going in
you're going into k rock he's like yeah
i gotta whatever and i go okay
just tell them there's gonna a boxing
guys come down here trainer i get a
trainer i'm gonna be by the elevators
i'll just wait here
but tell them to come out and i don't
know if they're on a break or commercial
break or who's in there or what you
um i just sit by the elevator and then
like
15 minutes later jimmy just comes around
just comes down the hall just comes
walking down the hall and he just goes
hey you you're the boxing guy and i go
yeah i'm the boxing trainer he goes
okay and i go okay and he goes
all right i go you want me to be your
boxing coach and he's like
okay i go okay when do you want to start
and he goes
today and i go okay let's start today
okay well i gotta go back in like finish
the job i go
destiny dude and he goes how about i go
when can you meet me is it noon
i go okay noon body's in motion pasadena
i'll be like at the
parking structure across the street i'll
give them the address because okay see
that
it goes back in the building i go back
my truck drive back you know
then i'm just standing out there you
know 12 and jimmy comes pulling up
beat to [ __ ] rx7 i'm like well this is
show business
because i've had bondo all over you know
parks
truck and parks is rx7 and i go okay
and we just we go down the body's in
motion
we train for like 20 minutes and i'm
like you want to get a snapple
and he's like yeah let's get a snaffle
we go up to the cafe this is what
snapping was a big deal
upstairs and for two hours we just sit
there talking about our favorite
comedians
and comedy and shooting the [ __ ] sort of
falling in love
and it's like he doesn't really want to
train and i don't really i want to talk
comedy you know
and before you know it the fight's
coming up in like three weeks you know
and i'm like
i don't know what happens after the
fight because i'm the boxing trainer guy
i called in the station a time or two
like worked
i worked a joke in like i would work but
i didn't want him to think i was the guy
who wanted
to be a comedian yeah yes because i
didn't want to freak him out like i just
want to be a comedian
i want to know i was a boxing trainer
you know
so the fight ended uh
the judges for the fight were how did
jimmy do
he lost what did you teach him i i
couldn't teach him anything
i couldn't i i i tried to do a thing
there's a picture of me and jimmy
getting into the ring
in what was called the uh blita in
resida
it took place at the merceda country
club um was he nervous
not not really which was weird he wasn't
that concerned about it
pat o'brien called it adam sandler was a
judge
wow and if you go to the left upper left
you see a picture of me
with my hat on backwards while jimmy is
wearing my old boxing trunks leaning
against the ropes and michael the
maintenance man is pummeling him
that's me with my body's emotion hat and
t-shirt on
i sent him out for the second round with
no mouthpiece i remember that
i remember like the bell rang and the
guys were fighting and at some point i
looked down i was like
what's this extra mouthpiece doing in my
hand like was my first dog my second one
was oh
but you know they had to face guard on
which kind of how long how long did you
fight for it i think it was like three
minute rounds or three three minute
rounds or whatever it was
but the the long and the short of it was
if you go to the bottom left corner you
can see like an old picture of
me and jimmy and i'm dressed up as uh
mr birch i'm the woodshop teacher
jimmy's wearing the glasses
yup he's in the middle so
we got to the end he lost the fight
and i i was like well now
what like what could i do but you guys
create some sort of bond
i'm sure throughout those weeks yeah you
guys would always hit it off
immediately and he said like
do you have any tape or you have
anything that you've done
and i shot some eagle rock like public
access
home improvement thing and it was
totally rough
and totally public access and totally
whatever
but i said that's what i got and he said
i'll look at it i gave it to him
and you know the genius of jimmy he like
saw
something in it like he was like oh this
guy's good for
some reason even though he's totally raw
so jimmy got it and he said
he goes well what do you do like what's
your thing
and i said i just shoot this [ __ ] man i
just sit
and roll with the punches and add to the
conversation
can you imagine you and i would be like
well good luck with that right
so what do i do he looks at me and goes
well that's what kevin and bean do
and i go yeah what i would do is like
sit in between them and like make them
better you know and he's like no that's
different
it's never gonna work you're the boxing
coach you're not coming into the studio
and
hanging out and cracking wise and i was
like
well what do you what's your suggestion
and he's like the only way you're
getting on with kevin and bean
is you got to come up with a character
and i was like
i don't really do voices or characters i
don't really do stuff
corolla yeah right
uh any more gray poupon so i go
i'm not it's not really my thing you
know i'm kind of me
you know and he's like well you better
make it your thing
and figure it out and that was like on a
friday
and he said call in monday
i'll give you the number i'll give you
like the hotline number i'm not going to
tell those guys who you are
because if they find out you're my
boxing coach they're going to be like
i don't want to talk to the boxing coach
guy or he's doing a character i mean
think about what that sounds like
right so he goes i'm not going to tell
him who you are i'm just going to go
i know funny guy you know he'll do a
character like trust me
and then he said they're probably not
gonna like it
and it'll probably be the last one you
do
like you're gonna it's gonna be one and
done like he wasn't saying it's gonna be
one and done but you know you're batting
average on your stupid character with
your boxing coach
and i'll ask if you can call in next
week and they'll probably go like
wasn't that good so i like went
okay i don't know i don't have any
characters
and but i sort of was gonna fall back on
like my groundlings
training like i do know how to develop a
character and i do
i do i am trained to do this stuff
so i i went back and i was like
you know i was thinking okay you're the
you're the gay florist who's going to do
the movie reviews you know or something
it's like
i was like i'm sitting around going what
i compare
yeah why would i why would i call you
oh my god why would i call
in what would be my motivation for
calling a radio station like as a
character
and i started thinking about it and i
thought well
you have to go with something you know
like you have to go
a subject you know about and i knew
carpentry
really well and woodworking really well
and i was like
now but what's the character you know
and i thought
i always joked about my shitty junior
high
shop teachers and what dicks they were
you know mr
hensley and mr saponzi and how they
hated the kids and they kind of loved
wood and wood shop and
metal and everything but they hated the
kids you know like the surly
woodshop teacher you know and i was like
oh that would be good like the
mean wood shop teacher and then i was
thinking to myself
but why would the mean wood shop teacher
call kevin and bean like what what's his
motivation right
calling and so i started thinking about
it
it's like oh i know okay
so this guy mr burcham
the woodshop teacher he teaches remedial
wood
at louis pasteur middle school in
monrovia
that's his thing and he is calling in at
15 in the morning and the reason
he's calling in is while he doesn't
like k-rock or any of this new music
[ __ ] his kids all listen
they all have the clock alarm set to
k-rock
because their prime demo genius they're
a bunch of 13 year olds they're skaters
you know they love
k rock yeah so so i call in
and i go you know listen
i don't care about your music i don't
care about your nervosa and your
smashing dumplings and all your crap
music you know
you know i like sugar loaf and real
bands you know
and and but all the kids are listening
so give me a second just to kind of use
it as an intercom to like speak to the
kids
and then i i go off on the kids i'm like
i injured myself in the garage again i'm
not coming in that quimby mr some ponzi
with a sweater vest
he's going to be teaching my class i
don't need
look if one of you goddamn kids gets
near my drill index so help me god i'll
stab you when i come back
and leave the makita poster alone i
don't you will watch he's got a movie
set up it's blood on the bandsaw
you're gonna watch that and you put your
head on the desk and ride out the rest
of the period do you understand
you don't get up you don't touch my
tools you don't move around
and then i'd go like and then but hold
on there's one kid who's good you know
that kid's good
his name is brad higgins dog like brad
i've been thinking a lot about the cigar
box you're building your grandfather
thinking about a butt
joint i know we're talking about a dado
or rabbit joint or maybe a
dovetail or a finger joint but i i think
let's just go with a rabbit joint that's
a clean
you can set up the dado system on my
contractor shaw
if any other kids get up you're in
trouble brad listen to me
and i'm getting it all specific [ __ ] of
how this thing
would be built that's so good dude
about they they liked it it went well
yeah and they're like different have
that guy call in again next week and i
kept calling in and i kept it would you
and jimmy
talk after like what do you think jimmy
he was like yeah yeah i i called gmail
were they laughing like i wasn't really
because they'd have the meeting
after the show right you know and and
you know i'd be like jimmy
you know what'd they think ah they
thought it was okay they i think i think
you think i could i think i'd call in
call in again oh yeah i did the bircham
on on
yeah how long do you guys run on that
how
we did like i don't know four or five
seasons and now
it's back yeah now it's back i saw it
more
more seasons but how happy were you when
you called jimmy again how did going he
went
pretty well man well at the beginning it
was just like
i think you could call back next week
like i was just
living week to week to fight again those
moments when you surprise yourself
when you're desperate like i i the only
time i ever knew i
maybe had i you don't know if you're
talented you don't even know if you can
do this
and i had an audition for these agents
in new york and and you had to bring a
monologue
and i was looking at monologues and i go
i want to write a monologue
i was like i wonder if i'm allowed to do
it or not bring one in no and i wrote i
wrote a monologue
yeah i wrote a monologue as a new york
guy and i did it i had
no idea it was going to work i was so
[ __ ] terrified i was probably like 22
and i
i did this monologue was this new york
guy and
they were [ __ ] laughing and then he
goes where did you
where'd that come from and i go i wrote
it he goes
you wrote that i go yeah he goes you're
very talented it was the first time
anybody ever said
it was the first time i've ever heard
that you know when you hear that when
you when something works like that
you're like
maybe i can do it but you didn't know it
was working right adam you're just going
week you kind of going
just hoping to get i didn't know it's
radio so i have no idea what the
audience is laughing
they were like a little bit but it
wasn't overwhelming
but it was enough all i needed to do was
survive to go to the next round yeah you
know
and i and and i but i knew
that if the following week i went out
there and [ __ ] the bed
i knew they'd pull the plug on it and i
knew
i had to get you know eight or ten good
ones under my belt before i could turn
in a five
you know yeah so i worked really hard at
it
and it became like a sensation
and it was it was crazy so it's like i'm
backstage at the
at the acoustic christmas at irvine
whatever like with kevin and bean like
you know two months later
and all of a sudden like i hear henry
winkler like i had like celebrities
would hang out backstage and i hear
henry winker going
and and who's mr bircham where's mr
bircham that guy's a genius
like i said that's like [ __ ] and i'm
standing back there like i'm swinging
ahead
holy [ __ ] and so i'm like huh and i like
walk up to him
and i go uh i'm mr bircham
and he he does the two-handed handshake
with
i'm not even in show business at this
point i'm still working as a
boxing coach and a carpenter he shakes
my hand with two hands and he goes
nobody does what you do nobody can do
what you do
and i was like oh my god my mind was
blown
and then like in the same concert thing
duff kagan or something from the from
guns n roses like comes by and he goes
he's like sees me and he goes you're mr
bircham oh
man axel was way off axel thought you're
an
older dude i think axelrose is having
thoughts about me like i come from the
valley i'm working construction like you
and axel rose are
having a discussion about mr i get
signed from william morris because like
the head guy
mark itkin over there is a huge burcham
fan
i get on the love line everyone's this
huge mr bircham fan
and it was funny and that's why
who's so then so then and then you and
jimmy just kind of kept this
relationship
yeah well the the the thing that you
know about jimmy or you need to know
about jimmy is
i'm the guy's boxing coach and like 10
minutes
later i'm twice as famous as he is mr
birch
jimmy has been kicking he's been
knocking around
radio for seven years at this point like
he's in
tampa he's in he's in seattle he's
getting fired
from palm springs i come in and in two
months i'm a huge star
at radio and no one cares about him and
i was like
[ __ ] god and a lot of dudes would
have turned on me
like a lot of dudes that's that's the
point i would have went i'm not going to
help you with your next virgin bit or
i'm not going to edit the bit you're
like a lot of guys would have went hey
man good luck yeah
he just went i'll help you i'll do it no
i've never
met i never met him but i i uh i was on
the same plane with him and i watched
how he interacted with fans
he's just such a good [ __ ] guy man
he's almost he's like such an amazing
guy i've always liked this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespectful